Internet should be Oh Biden be Obama's
running mate in the next election if not
who would you like to see on the ticket
oh this comes up every job I don't they
mean Joe Joe Biden when I said building
said bill by oh no Joe Biden yes I mean
this I don't know why this is always a
interest to people but I I mean they
said the same thing when Cheney was the
vice president is he gonna be on the
ticket again um usually it's the same
guy but I don't know who else would it
be I don't think they've changed vice
presidents since like Lincoln yeah I
think he changed like I mean FDR had a
few different ones but he was yeah if
they are in a different possible weapon
he was there forever I mean they were
just probably dying on him but I don't
know I mean like a fine Hillary Clinton
get in just cuz it would blow the minds
of right-wingers from Costa Co and it
could have a good vice president Jack
and I know B etcetera better to run in
the next election and it's an easier job
I mean she must be exhausted the
Secretary of State job is very difficult
and that could be that wants to go on to
the next term a Secretary of State know
she's gonna be she's done she's done so
and she'd pretty much kill herself
before she drive yeah it's very know
that doesn't stop us from speculate and
that could have been the deal they made
when she took the job to begin with you
don't know what goes why would she kill
herself with she'd be business which I
did she said she didn't want to be VP
she's given the Sherman s denial yeah in
different ways they don't stop guys like
me yeah speculating about on our blogs
um what would you like would you like to
interview Sarah Penn Palin on real time
or however on the panel well of course
but I can't subpoena people
what do you make of the so called [ __ ]
walks taking place around the world oh
do you know what [ __ ] walks are there a
protest against people who think that
when women dress provocatively
provocatively that they're asking for it
and this has created an outrage it
started in Toronto but I think there's
like 75 of them around the country now
where women dressed scantily clad to
protest being judged for dressing
scantily clad Lee well I think I'm in
from in favor of them I think with
better plan sharing it on the chopping
block we probably a better use of our
time our feminist time than right that's
Petraeus right there you can think of
more things than than one it's not a one
you should thing but I would say in that
case there isn't a police officer said
to stop triplet women stop dressing
provocatively about it so to what excuse
tis used to children who are sexually
assaulted I mean what that that's such a
ridiculous thing to say that I just wish
it wasn't called [ __ ] walk I just that
kind of talk whether the emails whether
it's on MTV that for something that that
that drives me nuts because it actually
takes away from the issue even call it
that diverts well but on the other hand
just call me a [ __ ] walk draws into your
attention and you you know if they just
call it like women rock or something
like that you probably wouldn't pay
attention well I mean it's it's a it's a
perform a on the panel could I point out
one weakness you know if you have a
bunch of [ __ ] walking down the street
calling themselves [ __ ] and they're
holding up signs and they're they're
trying to take back the term you know I
think the message a lot of guys might
get is oh hey look there's a bunch of
slots enough perfect and it's not going
to be
and it's not gonna be do you know I
ought to think more about random power
me not that it isn't a perfectly valid
message to have just maybe there's a
more effective way to reach men there's
not but it's the most effective way to
reach men I promise you okay
what would the actual implications be if
we remove the tax-free status for
churches and religious institutions ah
well a lot of money into the federal
coffers I would guess first of all you
know I mean that's a bit a big business
there churches and you know they're
selling an invisible product I mean it's
a good it's a fantastic it's a fantastic
Israel let me
you know let me let me predict the
Republican it would be you're trying to
balance the budget on Jesus's back
something it wouldn't it wouldn't go
over well with Republicans that's right
because Jesus was a loyal American we
all know that is it unpatriotic for
large American companies to lobby for a
tax holiday that will allow them to
repatriate money they've earned overseas
yeah big corporations in my view are
very unpatriotic they don't and and you
know some of these companies that are
supposedly the ones that are you know we
all get down on the oil cover you know
that the bad guys but you know Google
which has this reputation as this hippie
company that their [ __ ] to I thought
I've read that they could make if they
had if they made there's product here in
America to China I think they'd still
make 50 percent profit I mean which is
what you make when you sell cocaine
still a very good profit yeah if we got
corporations actually pay that their
taxes in America we wouldn't probably
have to talk about lowering the tax rate
all the richest America
yeah I know that's a big Republican
talking point is that we have the
highest corporate tax rate in the world
yeah we have the highest rate we have
the lowest I think among the thirty
biggest industrialized nations of what
they pay of what they actually pay and
Pawlenty wants to lower it always a lot
of lawyers so are the other yeah balance
out of a that's always good all right we
got to go thank you folks we'll see you
next week
you